yesterday i tweeted out a whole bunch of
questions and some of the information i
learned about the early days of bitcoin
even i didn't know i found very very
interesting and so today what we're
gonna do is we're gonna start off by
going through a couple of early days of
bitcoin of things that you may not know
most people know that at october 31st
2008 halloween 2008 satoshi nakamoto
published the bitcoin white paper it's a
date that everyone knows on january 3rd
2009 the bitcoin blockchain was publicly
released most people know that date as
well but what you may not know is that
the first block is block zero it's not
block one block zero genesis block most
of you probably do know that you also
know this message here the times zero
three jan 2009 chancellor and brink of
second bailout for banks that is all
pretty much well-known knowledge now
let's go into the second tweet that we
have here i did not know this the first
thing is that the genesis block had 50
bitcoin in it obviously and satoshi
mined those 50 bitcoin but of the 50
bitcoin from the genesis block they
technically are not spendable so this is
not something where society went and
mined the 50 bitcoin and they could turn
around and have sold it to somebody or
even later once there was actual
liquidity exchanges infrastructure a us
dollar price assigned to it etc those 50
bitcoin and the genesis block are not
spendable so that was the first thing
that i think uh some people know that
but some people do not so some people
may find that interesting the second
thing was that the genesis block was
mined again block 0 on january 3rd 2009
the first one but block one which was
technically the second block in this in
the blockchain wasn't mined until
january 8 2009. so after the first block
that second block when it was actually
mined was five days later so it didn't
just come out and immediately have every
10 minutes or so of block after block
being mined so five days later was the
genesis block now if we go ahead and we
look why is january 8th interesting on
january 8 2009 that lines up with an
email that was sent from satoshi to the
cryptography email list on the same date
and the nakamoto institute has all of
the emails that are uh you can just go
to
satoshi.nakamotoinstitute.org you see
all the emails there this specific email
talks about announcing the first release
of bitcoin a new electronic cash system
that uses a peer-to-peer network to
prevent double spending obviously
bitcoin one of the big technical
innovations was preventing double
spending it's completely decentralized
with no server or central authority
pretty clear-cut concise two-sentence
description of what bitcoin is and then
you can obviously there's a link to
download it it is only windows for now
wasn't available anything else just
windows open source c plus plus code is
included and then there's some
instructions on how you can actually
start to use the blockchain so that
alone is interesting the first block 50
bitcoin and the genesis block not
spendable from a technical standpoint
the second thing is that the second
block block one was not actually mined
until five days later on january 8 2009
at the same time there was the email to
the cryptography list and the release of
the uh public client for uh for bitcoin
then lastly we have jamison lop showed
me yesterday that satoshi not only
didn't pre-mine bitcoin but
it uh that person or group didn't even
fast mine bitcoin but it actually
throttled down the miners now patoshi
and satoshi are not necessarily the same
person but patoshi is known as a person
or group that mined a ton of bitcoin
it's estimated around 700 000 bitcoin in
the first year and so what i found
interesting about this thing that
jameson pointed out is that
you can see in the data through those
block timestamp deltas that there was a
intentional throttling of the hash rate
so potoshi almost never mind blocks less
than five minutes apart this pattern was
revealed by sergio lerner in a recent
article at the time it was uh recent
about a year or two ago uh and then
jamison went and he actually verified it
himself and so what i think i really
kind of take away from a couple of these
details here is one is that there is an
immense constraint
in mining that much bitcoin never
spending it never touching it never
doing anything right kind of an
altruistic uh view of the world and the
launch of this uh product
two
is that there was a very very
intentional uh and powerful foresight to
understand what some of the critiques in
the future could be and also an
understanding of what a truly fair
democratic uh kind of powerful launch of
this asset would be and so i think that
what i'm gonna start doing is on a
couple of these shows i'm going to go
and i'm going to find tidbits from the
early days of bitcoin i'm going to bring
them up we're going to talk about some
of the things that if you've been in
bitcoin for a really really long time if
you were around especially uh you know
2009 10 11 12 13 14 then you may know
some of the stuff that was kind of newer
information but there's a whole new
class of people who are showing up in
2017 18 19 20 21 and they may not know
some of these details so we're gonna go
find a bunch of them for you and we're
gonna keep bringing them up and going
through it i think we may even at some
point go through some of the early
satoshi emails and really just walk
through like here was the conversation
that was happening in the early days
that people can wrap their heads around
it first block genesis block 50 bitcoin
not spendable second block wasn't mined
until january 8 2009 and then on january
8 2009 you also got this email to the
cryptography mailing list saying hey
announcing the first release of bitcoin
new electronic cash system that uses
peer-to-peer network to prevent double
spending download link windows only and
a bunch of instructions on how to
install it what did you guys take away
uh when you saw some of this information
i thought it was interesting it's always
good to look at critiques or things that
people could eventually say or problems
with the system or the infrastructure
kind of the origin of bitcoin and go
back and like learn history about it so
i think it was cool
i think it was cool that people came out
and gave their research and their
opinion and stuff like that uh but yeah
i think we should continue to do it and
and seek out not only the history of it
but the other side of the argument about
what people could eventually complain
about
john it's a new asset right it's over
just a little bit over a decade old
people are still learning about what's
going on today and the innovations in
the future but they're also obviously
still learning about what has happened
in the past and kind of how bitcoin got
started this isn't really concerning to
me in any sense it's interesting to me
um i did not know this but it's nice to
see that people are still going back and
learning about it um look it's a new
asset people are gonna continuously talk
about it and dig deeper and deeper into
the origins of